today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza is a
specialty pizza shop and it's a shop
where you can get that pie boy so what
I'm saying to you is go get it if you
think you can get some than you can
great block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard
on the way to the beach in Los Angeles
great block get that hitter today's
guest is the host of the Bert cast and
has a new comedy special on Netflix
which you should check out right now
called hey big boy it's the big boy
himself mr. Bert Kreischer
[Music]
did he really
I seen him swimming well I've seen the
way he swims I'm not surprised he
stroked his way into something he
doesn't he swims well but not like I
would swim you'd think those basketball
players would be Olympic swimmers yeah
well you could really first of all
getting in the pool you're a third of
the way there
dude I had a joke tell me when you're
rolling okay perfect
I had a joke in my last special secret
I'm not this special hey big boy which
is streaming right in anything right now
right now yeah I in my last missile this
is a true story Ralph Sampson you
remember our Sampson basketball players
out of cocaine no that's it Len Bias Len
Bias
Oh r.i.p man he died brah um yep Ralph
Sampson there's a true story by the end
of my Netflix special so no one watched
it ins but uh he he he won't he gave a
speech to us when we were Villanova wait
for like basketball camp and the two
takeaways was number one
he works hard number two he can't swim
that was enough like you never learned
how to sport card can swim it's his new
special yeah I can swim he said the
whole time his sister's are another swim
he just practice dribbling a basketball
huh never learned how to swim and my
whole thing I'm sitting and wat
listening to this speech and I go who
the [ __ ] needs to learn how to swim
you're seven feet tall anyone in the
pool you're still halfway and by the way
they will make these basketball players
would make such great swimmers Manute
Bol oh that [ __ ] stroke he'd be
scraping his knuckles on the bottom of
the pool just he could grab on to the
pool just drag himself across
oh he's built like Slenderman dude here
look I have seen Slenderman middle world
is very much built like my [ __ ] phone
off
I love turning my phone off these days
oh it's so nice I was just in Maui man
my phone was off a lot Maui
yeah I love Maui dude how nice is it oh
by the way all this happening is searing
is going you love Maui
yeah dude the phones won't even go off
if you set your phone and say hey Siri
turn my phone off I don't do I don't
know how to turn a phone iPhone off yeah
I've never I'll never turn off you just
hold this button right you have to hold
both buttons of the top but oh that
screen grab button - the whole time we
have to hold it for like three seconds
oh there you go I've never turned my
phone off it says a lot about my
personality yeah yeah all this chronic
virus going on my end my phone was like
you've actually spent 60% less time on
your phone oh yeah pretty cool it's cuz
of the special and I didn't like all
press was taken away oh yeah zero press
but but now were you exciting because
people are at home they need something
to watch I was excited cuz might you
know it's true but like my parents and
all my parents friends were at home but
they're not home like in a fun way like
they're in a home like in a scared way
and so for me I'd much I would much
rather have done the done the precise
setup done the promotion I had set up
all the marketing I had side dude I had
such a [ __ ] great plan I was gonna do
the call stick to work short text you
about that right call in sick to work
show yesterday same Mattie's day doors
open at 10:00 show starts 11:00 me bill
burr Jim Jeffries Sebastian Maniscalco
you D'Elia Tom Segura the list goes on
jo koy everyone right didn't release the
names on the tickets let's just send it
out to my fans on my phone number three
two three two oh eight oh eight four
four send it out to them said get
tickets sold out immediately do a live
podcast in the o.r tiger belly oh my god
who wouldn't see that live me and bill
Burt live in the or we had all this [ __ ]
plan and then they call huge they called
it and and by the way you want and now
this is the inside baseball part that's
where my brain works and Davis Pedro
McDonald coming by stop by for the
caustics torso on table it was
touch-and-go but yeah my plan was this
is where my brain works you thrown this
call in sick to work show you split all
the money with the comics you don't need
the money right right tip all the money
out all the comics and then all you ask
for all your friends is you give me a
shout-out on your social media and then
you get in front of like 70 million
people on Instagram [ __ ] 20 million
people 100 million people on Twitter
that'll go hey check out my boy Bert
Kreischer he's got a special streaming
that's my marketing coronavirus I did
not [ __ ] in let me hook you do you feel
do you feel like slighted do you feel so
do you feel taken advantage of No
cool do you feel like coronavirus is are
you really a hundred percent sold on it
yeah it's here's what they just came out
today and they said like blood type o
doesn't get it like you just you don't
you may get it you may be a carrier but
you don't feel it that's my the way news
is always changing I'm not a [ __ ]
doctor right but um but yeah I mean who
said it dr. Gupta that guy always trips
me out I want to see the horse side of
Sanjay did you know he was one of the
five doctors one hey man can you get me
on a TV show but he always seems cool
and collected like you know he's such a
thought bro he's such a [ __ ] I know
he's such a thought he was hip Indian
Way before hip Indians yeah I do Sanjay
Gupta is probably the first famous
Indian guy oh how easy is it to be a hip
Indian though it's like the if it seemed
like the easiest thing to do no it's
gotta be hard because your parents don't
want you to be happy
oh now there you go okay so like Russell
Peters hip Indian yeah
am ia yeah this guy named shot chunk
that I know this guy that used to go to
UCLA dude is here bro
it was like four pairs of sunglasses man
he's like an hip pulls out his wiener
sunglasses on it yeah the thing about
Indians you don't know stereotype that
they don't get out they're big dicks
know really big dicks Russell Peters
told me bro everybody's starting to get
on this big dick trainer used to be that
was a way to oppress minorities is to
say they did it with the Jews first the
I don't know if there's 100% true yeah
don't worry dude this whole podcast has
gone that direction already jinns said
it about the Jews they have big dicks I
don't have you seen hardship here's dick
it's [ __ ] massive ah he's doing a big
[ __ ] really really but also he looks
like he would have a dick that doesn't
look right
it doesn't yeah it does it in his balls
of weirdness yeah so yeah if I'm Ari
Shaffir
you think his dicks longer it looks like
he's trying to get off of his body
because that's totally different things
know he's got dick that goes right off
the body like his dick is right off the
body right my dicks got body around it
like pushing it back yeah so like oh
okay wow that's interesting yeah like
Nixon was being held back by the sides
of it it's got its got pubis going like
crowding it like like it's his boys
going like oh come on man get him get
him and hair and everything like come on
man get back in here no no no no my my
body looks like it's stopping my dick
from a [ __ ] no no holding back man
holding back that [ __ ] joke god damn
it good man use it next time you do my
dick definitely has a little you have a
big dick I've already heard really yeah
who told you that our mutual friends Tom
and Bill oh my god look at our he's dick
right there that is that's not fluffing
like that's unprepared that's just
straight Street dick
he has such a Holocaust body doesn't he
kind of like that was the Jack Holocaust
cuz that wasn't all was he really oh I'm
sorry then just for vacation Oh Artie
sorry I already drugged me I said I
don't blame Ari I blame Hitler for the
drugging yeah because Hitler did that
[ __ ] to his dad and you know his dad
probably won The Greatest Dad and then
he turned into Ari right so ultimately
it all falls on Hitler's shoulders it
all goes back man that's the thing you
have to stop the cycle yeah you got to
stop the cycle of hate you got to stop
the cycle of trouble it's always a cycle
you know someone always learned it from
somebody else
Oh learn the dirty behaviors you know
the M word first time I ever heard the M
word I was at I was in I was in first
grade and these black kids came into our
neighborhood we living in like a poor
white neighborhood and there was a poor
black neighborhood and like across
across across Nebraska Nebraska I forget
well dude that's pretty far then if
you're noticing no no no that was a
street name not the oh right hombre yeah
and so let's do
did not live by black stayed away so
then like what the Braska and we're
Florida and it was scary man it was
touch-and-go at times I'm weird stories
oh yeah the rumor mill I saw a note in a
bottle one time in the river a man oh
the N words you just said it so so these
these black kids lived across this this
Main Street from us and then they came
into our neighborhood I guess and stole
my football my football had a Duke jr.
with a shoelace a tan shoelace as the
string sweeps playing the street mm-hmm
and so the string for the shoelace
bricked my dad replaced it with a with a
with a tan shoelace
it was very distinguishable and a little
part we couldn't tie it so there was a
little like part of the ceiling and hang
out yeah so they came into our
neighborhood and they asked if they
wanted to play this a football and they
had my football hmm and these two
brothers Darrell and Darren like yo they
must I mean I when I remember this story
I'm never feel like they're 18 17
they're probably just like 10 of 11 yeah
and I was six
yeah and they were like yo this is
football and they're like no this is his
football this little other little black
kid and they're like fight him for it
and I was like I have the first grade I
was not fighting anyone I was wearing a
loincloth in knee-high moccasins oh yeah
and so Danny's fighting your sexuality
brother Pat it would be sucking dick so
uh so yeah me pants to do it what a
[ __ ] support the Union was on me back
like a madman
a backup gay dude that's you mind if I
pull my socks oh my god
bullocks up I want to skin my knees when
I suck your dick do you mind if I pull
my pants down oh [ __ ] what if I take my
shirt off and just hey is it cool if I
take my shoes off and put my knees in my
a little guy actually if you know some
dude that's not a bad like I would go
through all of those things before you
you gotta like you gotta have some ways
to get out of it you know I've gone down
on my wife on the side of the bed with
my knees on the on the wood floors now
that's a grab a pillow put them on your
knees yeah the but anyway so these black
kids come in the neighborhood and they
they're like fight this kid and I was
like I've never been in a fistfight I
want to be in a fistfight and then
Darrell and Darren looked at me like
like oh we gonna have to do this for you
and I was oh my head I was like give him
the [ __ ] ball I don't care my daddy
bought me a new one like out like and
then they got no fight big into a fight
Darrell fights one of the dudes or
Darren one of the one of the younger one
fights a black dude and they're all it's
like it's like five black kids and then
seven white kids or eight white cos the
more white kids who's our neighborhood
and the dad comes out and the dad starts
chanting funny fight and we're in a
white white don't win we all jump in and
I am and then he's hitting me it's your
ball [ __ ]
Janet Janet and Here I am just some
first grader in a loincloth and
knee-high moccasins just fight fight and
then I said then I said the word in
front of my dad and it was [ __ ] over
really Oh dad fought him no no no my dad
took me down to their [ __ ] house walk
me down stood in the [ __ ] thing I
said don't ever talk to my son don't
ever I told my dad I've been in half and
they stole my ball is what he asked me
to say so
talk to my son and we moved out of that
neighborhood month later month later we
were out of that [ __ ] neighborhood
because people were using the n-word oh
that was that was the least of it we let
it come on fire I mean it was yeah look
this kid on fire John and he had you
know thing at table like a margarine
bowl with gasoline mm-hmm and there's
this abandoned house that these that
these people left him there always is
why do people leave it in abandoned
house by children do they were the
funnest especially do you ever break
into abandon house there was a there was
a asian couple that my friend my
friend's parents were watching their
house there like a dog or a cat or
whatever yeah he was like you want to go
in and see their house man this is like
night this has gotta be 1977 t97 a UH
like no one knew no one I mean not no
one but I'm saying like no one it
floored a new Asians then yeah and we
went in early things were like things
were like turquoise walls like turquoise
blue with big buddha statues and like
everything was just different smelled
different rewards like a style number
like a samurai on the big feathers
coming out of vases yeah and you were
like whoa people talking to you from
behind fans yeah they had dog they had a
dog right so then so then this kid one
day goes same house he goes yo he wanna
go swimming throw outside a pool I was
like yeah we were first grade my mom had
a station wagon she drops him off first
comes out drops me off and he goes meet
me back at my house with a with your
swimsuit I'll go back I'll get us our
backyard
they had a Doberman Pinscher oh yeah
they don't have that many of those
anymore no one's sure you know what it
is I talked about my special but it's a
purebred purebred czar they're all
[ __ ] dying out oh yeah they got like
a doe bore doodle or something like that
they had to mix them because the pure
breads were getting all these [ __ ]
problems in their body because they were
breeding for like over breeding it's you
know same thing as Hitler Hitler won the
war blonde chicks been walking around
with hip dysplasia
really yeah especially like that jump
nice I have just please yeah in your
hips yeah Brody's like a dragon Shepard
Brody Stephens had dysplasia really do
we do you walk odd yeah kind of a little
bit if I have to walk for a long time I
could have to walk for a couple of miles
it gets bad really yeah just like I kind
of get that shake you know I think it's
cute but it's cute it hurts a little but
yeah but yeah but but um anyway enough
about me
but yeah the n-word man it'll fly out of
you you know that's why I long time ago
I used to joke where I said I don't say
the n-word because I care about people I
don't say it because if you get if your
tongue gets used to it if you say it a
bunch behind doors or whatever and if
you feel comfortable saying it one night
you'll get drunk in your tongue it'll
slip out of your mouth and you'll be in
the wrong [ __ ] place my dog I don't
say it first
that's my rule dude you know somebody
else has to say go as long as you go
alright we're good we're good
you can't ever be the person to say it
first that's that's crazy man but I
think like a lot of stuff where you
can't you like like yeah you can't use
the word right like I get it yeah but I
think also like um I think some [ __ ]
am I was gonna say man yeah you just
don't use the word anymore I think the
only place that still really uses it is
mostly music these days I don't hear
what people say it anymore I don't hear
anyone say I've never I'm not heard
white people say it growing up in the
South I mean all of us that grew up in
the south heard it yeah and and her
white people use it out of McDonald's or
some [ __ ] and there was no cameras
around so no one got outraised
but yeah the only place you really hear
its music I'm in my bus drivers black so
I hear it all the [ __ ] time oh yeah
yep but it's like I told the girls one
time the girls were in the car and there
they go daddy went every joke and I was
like yeah so tell me the joke like that
dot and then the punchline they're like
he's a [ __ ] and I was like hey guys
you can't say that word and they're like
why I go cuz it's like a bad word and
they're like no it's not I don't know it
is and like I was just describing a
person I go I understand that but you
can't say it cuz if you say that word
and someone's you know a little person
they hear it it might hurt their
feelings and my daughter's look to me
and they like they're not in the car dad
it's just us
I was like yeah you'd think it would
work that way and then Brad Williams
came to my house and I was like I broke
oh bring the girls in the man cave I go
hey won't you tell Brad that joke and
they lit up like wow calling you yeah
but you know like put him on the spot
yeah dude I remember they had armor
fishing with the black buddy of mine
named Evan and he went to jail actually
for murder or alleged murder really but
um we were fishing in some kids were up
on the like on this railroad track like
up up up this up this embankment from
this river and they started throwing
rocks and called us the n-word right and
I'm like not me you're gonna back to the
back of the boat I think they're talking
to you Desmond yeah
you're aiming horrible but I remember
that was scary man I mean yeah you
definitely had some people that like I
mean I think racism is just kind of like
I mean it's just definitely like how
crazy would be of coronavirus a black
hawk who can get coronavirus someone
said that they can't but they need Reese
Alba got it I know somebody said gay man
can't get it there's a lot of
information can't get it that's what I
heard but then I think Siegfried or Roy
got it can you see that magician gets
corona alleged magician I wouldn't they
just go tada I don't have any more
they're dead man if they get corona
they're dead yeah magician gets corona
see any guy was aging magician yeah his
thing is the aging magician he's my leg
hurt so bad oh [ __ ] a dub came out of it
[Laughter]
he just stands there on stage and he's
like I'm aging yeah we can all do that
when I was growing up you knew not say
the n-word if somebody beats her ass
that's how you knew you know what I'm
saying like that was the litmus it was
like you that's how you learned about it
it was like Oh somebody said it somebody
got their ass beat and then that was it
it's so funny man I never heard it like
I'm not heard it when I was when we
lived in that neighborhood and then I
never heard it in our new neighbor had
never heard it and then I never I never
heard it and I heard it a little bit in
high school but but it was we had a
black friend Corey Brown and all the
kids that grew up with him would drop
the word but as a like not not
derogatory just I was like a joke if if
it was the pot like ana-lucia
it was the punchline of a joke meaning
towards car Eeyore but very
light-hearted they were like guys that
he grew up his whole life and then I
heard a lot in college I heard it
[ __ ] well I went to Florida State and
we were segregated it was like FAMU in
Florida State so I heard it a lot
College Sammy was more black college a
hundred percent yeah and I used to drive
the black chicks they'd call they always
lived in one dorm it's so funny I ran
into this woman the other day who went
black took my age mm-hmm
I went Florida State and I said hey did
you ever take safe escort that's what I
was I Drive him around campus and like a
k-card remember a cake our Papa cake our
can you it was like the [ __ ] the
biggest beater you could ever have yeah
I think it's called a cake or a cute car
it's like old yeah yeah oh yeah Renault
that's uh that's a Renault isn't it okay
that was a that was what it was white
and so and then they would what would
happen is you knew if the black chicks
called
on a Saturday night cuz you it was just
taking people to the libraries where you
supposed to go okay but if the black
chicks call on a Saturday night you knew
they wanted to go to family you from
Florida State okay and we weren't
allowed to drive to FAMU but once they
got in the car you had to take them
wherever they went so what would happen
was they go they go we about pick up a
Debbie Nihal one based one lemon I have
a pickup at Debbie Hall her name's
Laquisha and you go okay you be like is
it how many is passengers like just one
that's what they say and so you'd pull
up and then she'd like wave to you and
you go hey and as she waved they pile on
the other side of the car then they go
we're going to fam you [ __ ]
I loved it though because I because I
love hip-hop yeah I was just talking
about with him the entire time every I
learned about wu-tang clan that way I
bought the Method Man album through them
I learned about a swab house yeah MJG
and 8-ball
it was like ham it was like the funnest
for me because I loved hip-hop oh yeah
so we would just I would be like what
are you guys listening to and I was
driving him for like [ __ ] 20 minutes
so we're listening to what there was no
player and there was no player in there
sometimes they'd have and we all wearing
seatbelts and everything Oh there'll be
so many people I was back seat belts
were like he won't even dive back in did
I see my kids put on seat belts I'm like
what are you guys putting I mean knee
pads were blood
what do you got to put your shoes in
your knees in your Asics where you blow
a guy kicked out your insert yeah yeah
time we're just I don't know if yeah I
don't know man I guess they had like I
didn't I don't know if I felt like I saw
a lot of racism I never hung out in like
a redneck type of area like I felt like
there was more there was also a lot of
racism but from black to white to like
black kids weren't like hey like us you
know there was a lot of like anger it's
it's funny you always have anger from
like previous generations like oh it's
always like the shit's always so
misdirected you know I feel like it's
like I told a story about one of my
specials about my first throwin I'm
probably dumb about either one of the
first fight like full-blown nah I say
fights like in high school there were
fights where was a big fight and you
stood on the outside and waited to
sucker punch someone and then there are
fights where you got sucker-punched or
hit with something I got punched one
time yep dude I got hit with a [ __ ]
somebody hit me with a bunch of
encyclopedias literally one a B C dude
and but I got to either I [ __ ] gave
up you're like I get it man come from
you meters are barks bees caterpillar
I'm done man
the the first fight I was in where it
was like squared up one-on-one bro that
is a there was the guy his name's
Donovan Donovan white guy black dude
straight state wrestling champ
you know cow head you know cow head my
cows right my cow have found him he
still lives in Tampa Wow my father found
him on MySpace is how long ago that was
found him and found his daughter and
said we'd love to have you come in
studio will corroborate this story and
he was like how much and cowards like
nothing I'd rather just hear the good
story so I haven't heard from this guy
he had an IROC right hit with the string
shirts he would shake his [ __ ] eye
Rock like to warm up for a fight just
shake it back out of sexy big wheels on
the back so he gets in a fight with this
guy these guys names Mario I think I'm
not sure I can't remember yeah yeah yeah
he gets in a fight with this guy Mario
and there's a bunch of black dudes
around and
I run in to see that I want to watch the
fight right and I peeked my head in and
the second I peeked my head in Mario's
unconscious he knocked him out clean oh
and he's holding his hair and as soon as
I put my head in they go
here's another one get him Donovan and
they pushed me in and now it looks like
I'm on his team
it sucks we're wearing the way the worst
about people outside of a fight all they
want is more fighting get him he wants
get him and bro squaring up to a dude
and I'd never squared up I had never
liked I was just trying to apologize and
then I realized oh he was gonna beat me
up he's glaring up the worst it's ever
done it which foot do you put first I
left left I said like I was like I've
had just square up twice against one
dude dude is in my life this other dude
I screwed up against I know I screwed up
do you remember the story when we were
doing reality bites back when we were
doing this oh you think you can dive
episode okay I drove us all down there
do you remember that yes I drove all
down and the practice day the practice
day that we had and for those who don't
know it was a show on Comedy Central
that was it was a great great show to be
on it was a lot of fun it's a big payday
it was cool not it wasn't big pay to a
big payday for baby for you though yeah
be crazy for they [ __ ] up it was it
was I'm gonna say this number is the
wrong number but it was in my memory it
was like $8,000 in episode yeah and but
and so all of us looked at it more like
it's a 10 that order episode officer
like we got an 80 [ __ ] grand then the
winner gets like quarter of a million
dollars whatever or a hundred thousand
dollars yeah and then we got through the
first day and realized if you get kicked
off you don't get a grant yeah and it
came they came Cutlass the only episodes
you were on you got eight grand for each
episode you were on I remember the
episode somebody got kicked off me you
I've told this story every time so right
grant a week ago really in Baltimore
yeah
he I think I saw the picture he came out
to my show yeah really cool it's great
to see him oh hung out with him in
Dunellen episode of something's burning
with them and we end up smoking weed
just [ __ ] that's awesome um the
first day the very first day were
sitting at that mansion outside of in
Encino it's me you read grant donnell
rawlings on the step mm-hmm if I'm not
mistaken and Kyle cease came up and he
had the Hat that said
week one he had a hat made out for every
week week 1 week 2 week 3 week 4 and
he's with Chris Fairbanks yeah and he
goes and Donnell goes yes son that's
right you are the week 1 and we all
start laughing and Kyle goes I I think I
think it's spelled everything there's no
no son you should have had that just
says week and then Kyle goes Donnell I
think it's I think it's spelled
differently and he goes not in my
neighborhood
and then Kyle walks away I go Chris and
he just goes he goes I think I'm next
and just walked away was so funny me you
me you read grant got naked in the
bathtub with luenell oh yeah yeah yeah
like I got full-blown naked yeah he
always did I got full of Megan I got
full-blown naked dick against the glass
and the president Lauren creo is in at
that shooting president Comedy Central
and it's what happened is me you and me
you and reg get a passage to the next
round and they go your reward is you get
to shower and bathe with Linnell
and so we're like oh [ __ ] it we don't
care yeah so we go in she's small I
think they gave him a small body I think
they give us cocktails we were drinking
before that yeah yeah and she got us in
there yep Oh picture of luenell I ran in
her by the way I thought she hated me I
ran into her in Montreal mm-hmm just got
[ __ ] wasted with her and had a blast
oh yeah she's fun everybody loves her
and we got in the bathtub and luenell
goes I'm taking off my drawers or
whatever oh yeah pulls her bathing suit
bottoms office oh no I'm out and I was
like [ __ ] I'm in so I take mine off
ready takes his off you take yours off
and then she stands up and she still got
him on getting to Paris praise God man
those are the good old days look I don't
think about how long ago that was it
sure was fun one year was that go back
to that information if you don't mind
Nick 1994
derived from 1994 uh 2008 Wow I got a
special right after that 2008 2008 Wow
someone wait whoa keep up who got voted
off when someone sent me a sip drive
that has all the episodes too I have it
on a drive someplace if either of you
want that I would
love to see that musically I was when
like look people I think a lot of people
in this business take ownership of when
they find when they feel like they
discover someone they know like like
there's a lot of agents that do that I
would say without a doubt without a
doubt me and Amy Schumer became the
biggest deal of all fans in the [ __ ]
world like I remember me and Amy looking
at each other and being like you were so
funny and it was effortless you weren't
even trying to be funny you were just so
[ __ ] funny I swear to God I pay
$100,000 to have all the footage raw
footage I got my own show of the
outtakes
there were times where you'd leave
Michael Ian Black just like huh and we
were not crying laughing he was like a
white supremacist I felt like it laid
rest
I remember we go we were all talking and
he we go so what do you hope the show
get to you what I hope to show it to you
all you have to get special I love you
get 30 minutes I love to get on premium
bland and me like what about you Michael
and he goes a new basement and we're
like what he goes that's the only reason
I'm doing this show I need a new
basement and we were like cool yeah he
always had this white supremacist body
he just looked too white I broke white
down a little you know really bring him
a picture of him just look he does have
a vibe of like like like the bad guy in
a Harry Potter movie Michael Ian Black
yeah he did he yeah he texted me last
night
he was so funny yeah I'll see if I can
see the text he's literally just texted
me last hour my [ __ ] phone oh there
he is right there he definitely looks
like he would be given a speech about
hey you know no prob sorry I have here
sorry white women vote looks like he
doesn't blink his eyes at night water
okay what's that one Michael Ian Black
defends louis c.k oh that's kind of cool
well MIB is a cool dude man I love him
dude he's one of a kind for he really is
man it was by the way he's always been
sweet like ever since we met him he's a
ballbuster kind of like that's his angle
of comedy but he's always been very
sweet guy I remember we connected
because
both our wives are older than us and I
yield yeah yeah and his wife's older
than him and my wife's I mean me MIB are
the same age and and did you ever see
his TV show the state yeah I want to dip
my balls in acid
how great was that it was the greatest
[ __ ] show I feel like I feel like
what I'm hearing is you don't like the
tacos no I love the tacos in fact that
the best tacos I've ever had dude that
that show was so [ __ ] great did you
ever see a thousand pounds of pudding oh
yeah oh dude I could watch that show
that was one of my favorite shows that
was the first time I really got comedy
Wow put type in no put I've been putting
the state yeah yeah yeah yeah there you
go
that was I think it was $240 worth I'm
sorry I said a thousand every time I
[Applause]
[Music]
they were like what it dollars can buy
we had the 240
maybe we could've bought $100 with the
puddin and that would have been a lot of
progress whether we had to go all the
way there always with 240 dollars with
the pudding now I know what you're
thinking marrying the bomb
where did you get 240 dollars don't
worry your pretty little head about a
baby in your concerns now if you excuse
me I got a whisper some sweet nuts just
put I'll just be over here minding my
own they were children
this is like the silliness [ __ ] yes
we're in college we were college we used
to go to parties ago yeah we did I can't
I can't
does anyone have some orange juice I've
got some orange juice
I want to dip my balls in that guy
Camerino ya ever run into you ever run
into people like you were fans of as a
kid that are fans of yours oh I run it
in this lady from in the heat of the
night can you bring up a picture of that
show actually she played out Thea Tibbs
you ever seen in the heat of the night
is that with the guy from Archie Bunker
yep Carroll O'Connor yes Barry right
here my apartment Althea Tibbs right
there oh I know few tips wait out the
attempts been a lot of [ __ ] yeah wait
what did you mean Althea uh him get to
her wiki maybe yeah that's her a Marie
Johnson
it's live in Los Angeles yeah I met her
she's seeing a man she's seeing a man
but when I saw I saw her a couple times
at different restaurants i costed her
mildly outside of the credit union
outside of the sag after credit union
just you trained you look at all the
stuff she's been in million thing oh
dude she's still working she's worked
forever but yeah she looked great and I
just told her I say hey I'm just such
the biggest fan she started working
before I was born
that's crazy Wow Matlock
Matlock was so good I mean you talk
about like the meat
doing all [ __ ] racism and [ __ ]
sexism in Hollywood imagine the [ __ ] she
had to deal with start I bet she'd
appreciate the fact that we at least
knowledge it
she started in 1971 1972 to 76 she was
on Matlock police I was I was I was when
I was born and then going different
strokes she was on difference I
guarantee you she dated Willis oh yeah I
guarantee it I met I met Arnold one time
you did from Hey Arnold
no no Arnold no from Arnold who Paul not
on well Arnold Palmer no Arnold from
different folks Arnold
Willis no the little one Oh Gary Gulman
no no Gary Coleman Gary Coleman Gary
Coleman Gary Coleman yes he died Gary
Coleman died Gary Coleman oh yeah
no Gary Coleman is going people out of
us be comedians over daily tweet his
advice and I'm like I don't think I'm
doing copyright I'm not writing at all
tag it nine different ways I tell you
once and it's good to go I don't know
what yeah I think I met Gary Goldman
Gary Coleman I met Gary Coleman Gary
Coleman died we looked at up please Ned
yeah
who was the kidney failure he really did
yeah because yeah yeah the little little
guys get kidney problems and so I think
that's how mini-me died I think that's
how a to died oh he's a beautiful young
man too from my died in Utah at 42 oh my
god you know they gave him a lot of
grief towards the end of his life member
all that they put him in a show called
midgets verse mascots at one point
remember that can you imagine the
Michigan State Trojan fighting a couple
of midgets off outside of a bakery or
whatever wherever they shot it look at
this [ __ ] I love how Hollywood acts
like like regular people or the problem
when they're doing shows called midgets
reverse mass my question who at the
University of Michigan was like yeah
yeah I think that's cool if a bunch of
little people show up and say hey this
is the show we want you the only you
have to be supportive would
leaving the midgets biscuit why would
they pick some when they definitely
can't beat how do I get midgets verse
mascots I gotta see this ha ha wait
Scottie Pippen's in it ron jeremy Jason
Mewes yeah I think they put spot they
put regular hiding people into the arm
mascot eree into the uniforms oh my god
I will definitely watch midgets first
mascot um yes Wildman can you believe
that that they have that kind of stuff
dude do you think do you think that
there's gonna be that we'll be able to
get back to regular humor after this
coronavirus thing I think I think it's
going harder I think we're gonna go
harder in the paint yeah because yeah
because right like I'll tell you right
now when this special when we were
editing this special I have she she had
a question for us actually we'll get
right into that but your statement let's
get this question real quick idea from
Ally semi relator what you guys talk
about okay beautiful beautiful lady
right there shocked when you see a
pretty person that's senior stand up and
you're like you saw me yeah like I get
it if you're like 280 pounds you got a
beard you're troubled yeah yeah yeah
you're like dude we all go through this
yeah but when you see her you're like
huh what happened um there's nothing
awesome there's only been one subject
that Isla asked me not to talk about but
like I talked about her period
I'll to get her period no special
they're pretty cool with it although I I
gotta be honest with you I don't know
you know the long-term effects of it I
don't wish I did you know I mean not in
a bad way but you don't it's like I
don't and it's dad's gone he's a
comedian you know saying he's dry he's
flying around the country telling people
all my period I don't know I I don't I
don't I can't imagine it's gonna be
awesome like I you know
you don't put any thought into it here's
how it works is that right so I'm on the
road with at the time it's me Segura and
impact are doing Irvine and Brea every
Tuesday every Tuesday Wednesday right
we're just banging out Tuesday Wednesday
Tuesday Wednesday not on Terry just
Irvine and Brea musescore driving out
and then one day you tell a joke the
first joke I wrote about the girls was
Isla was a babyish and she had she woke
up early in the morning I go downstairs
I hear my baby monitor go downstairs I'm
like what's going on nor why you
laughing George's in a rocking chair I
was naked and you're just like dad you
guys see baby Islands new trick the dogs
in between them I don't [ __ ] know and
I go what is it she goes I don't want to
spoil it for you
I'll show Dad and Isla takes her finger
shoves it up her ass and puts in the
dog's mouth oh that's the first joke I
wrote about my daughters and it the
Jolly Roger we call the happy Nazi and
so I go and so I tell that story onstage
in both the in and Tom are like bro
that's like that's legit funny it's not
a kid joke that's just a funny [ __ ]
joke like we don't have kids and we
still like it and that was where I flip
the switch and so then no then Islands
maybe two or three or just four or five
you start writing jokes about your kids
and they're definitely not seeing it
they're not seeing at all and then I do
the Machine and I put all those stories
I haven't about the girls and it starts
to work like people start to relate to
it
I do secret time and that's when they
were like they were like hey like like
kind of curious like what do you say
about us I was like guys it's not a big
deal
this one they were like you know run
everything past us first and so I had to
run the period joke past Island she was
a did you sit down and talk to her about
it I told her well I put it here's what
how you know me man I put her on [ __ ]
Instagram stories the day it happened so
the day it happened she gets her period
she wants to a period party do they do
that now oh yeah it's big time what oh
yeah a period part yeah
I told part of the story on her own I
told just a part of the story on Conan
and it got 20 million views immediately
so like she good she's like I don't want
to ruin it watch this special but she I
get I get all the stuff for the period
party I dress in red
what like [ __ ] red velvet cake you're
gonna love do you love this bit you'll
love this bit but my point is I put it
all on Instagram stories that night
because I'm laughing I'm dying laughing
and then I get in bed that night she
comes in she's like hey big boy I need
you to take that down and I go but I go
baby it's it's it's fine I think it's
cool she was yeah I know I don't mind
people knowing I through a period party
but I don't want kids in my school
knowing I had my period yeah and I went
oh okay
that makes sense so I pull it all down
and then I go to Louisville that next
weekend and I talk about it I tried
onstage and just that just that reaction
you just had is the whole room Savin it
but the weird part you know me I'm a
meathead I'm like a [ __ ] mouth
breather mm-hmm is women are connecting
with it going like cheering for I love
which I think cool so then I work it out
a little bit I talked out about it and I
was like I want to do part of that story
on Conan and she's like she goes why I
go I think it's good I think it's a good
thing I think that the thing that you're
doing is gonna be good for little girls
and other little girls will see it and
if the trauma the Georgia with Georgia
on her period she was a [ __ ]
nightmare
and I said the trauma George went
through you can help them avoid that
Kyla didn't want to go through what
Georgia went through so she just
circumnavigated and went I'm gonna
celebrate this moment right and so I
told her all Conan she watched his she
was cool with it but then the next day
my email gets flooded with little girls
emailing me like their parents their
parents are emailing me from their
daughters like this my daughter wants
you to once you read this and letters
coming in to my manager Lee like hey I
was really scared about getting my
period I've been really nervous about it
but I saw your dad's story thank you for
letting him tell it and then an island
named her period and they go and by the
way we just welcome Daryl to our family
and so it was so like I don't I don't
have any limits like I'll talk about
[ __ ] anything whether or not it goes
into a special it's like another thing
cuz I got her I gotta run it by them
damn like and I know it's gettin it's
gettin touchy for Georgia yeah yeah I
could imagine but yeah I could imagine
that that's a lot going on she's 15 and
when she starts [ __ ] up and you want
to talk about it you know she's gonna be
like you imagine if you're if all your
fuck-ups
oh I couldn't yeah
and so it's I don't know man I will see
who knows maybe I won't make it out of
this coronavirus and that's the end of
my stand-up yeah it'd be interesting
here's a white guy right here with
something to say yo what's up Bo what's
up bird that's Logan from Sarasota
Florida my question for bird is how
excited are you for all that new
material you're gonna get for being
quarantine with both your daughter's
it's gonna be hilarious and then my
question for both you guys this do you
ever go back and watch your old Netflix
specials and try to build off that for
your upcoming shows it's a great gang
gang that's a great question it is a
good question man oh the first part he
asked us for you yeah I'm uh it's only
been two days so I'm not super excited
yet hey yeah it's funny you start
picking out little things that you I
mean you know that like there'll be
something that happens where you go
that's not it but this may be a part of
it right and so like right now Isla is
obsessed with puns mm-hmm so anything
you say to where she replies in a pun
I guess there's just some guy on the
internet who does puns and so she loves
puns grip lists there's a guy named
grepolis that's an artist you can bring
him up but yes really good ones but uh
but yeah I don't know D when you prepare
for a special do you watch previous
specials I've honestly I've never
watched my old special um you know I saw
whenever we're editing it and putting it
together uh I wasn't really in I wasn't
that stupid that stoked about it but I
loved it he did I loved it I watched it
on the foot of my bed before we changed
our house around I remember exactly
where I was I put turning on I watch
someone the foot of my bed I watched you
getting ready for it to like I've never
seen you get ready for it the Hollywood
improv yeah yeah I was excited yeah I
mean I think that's just my head you
know it's like you always everyone's
head yeah do you trust me sorry trust me
I did not I was so like press has been
very weird for this special and like cuz
we they just pulled all press so there's
no press so crazy yeah and it's dude
because did you have a lot of place to
go this together you were lined up - I
had lined up across the board and then
and then you know everything happened
and they just pull all press and I'm
doing four podcasts that's it for the
whole special for [ __ ] podcasts and
so well thanks for coming in you know
dude thank you by the way hold on you're
one of the few people that didn't cancel
on me a lot of podcast can swell really
yeah a lot of podcasts were like no
we're not you know what can we push it
like a week and just see what's happen
I'm like I'm like man unless someone's
you know in it you know unless you're
showing any symptoms and by the way
everyone's been [ __ ] quarantined the
rules 10 or under it's 10 or under and
they're being safe on that it's three of
us in a room he's not I'm in the same
room no one's touched each other so like
me it's Segura did a podcast this
morning everyone's like look people are
[ __ ] working you can't not make a
living or entertain people that are
locked up in their houses this is what
we do for a living yeah totally and if
anything is a time to do this is a time
to be like I'm doubling down on Park if
I did have it I'd come in and do it oh
yeah by the way I wouldn't mind one of
us just getting it and spread it to all
of you going hey guys let's really bang
these out now or I'll do it sex again
yeah just really affected yeah now we're
done yeah affected only yeah I wonder if
it at some point there will become a
line where it's like the affected get to
do stuff and the unaffected don't get to
do it's like a herpe with herpes website
no party with us well I thought if one
day there was like a what if one day
they come out with a drug where you can
live forever right but only some people
get it you know and some people don't
and there's just gonna be that crazy
like cutoff like they're gonna decide
like well you're over 45 you know you're
not even abuse or you're over six you're
not abuse anymore so you don't do that
already so you don't get it but under 60
gets it and the government has it and
it's like it's just gonna be this crow
right where they draw the line and you
gotta [ __ ] pick it marriages if your
wife be two years three years older or
whatever she can't do it I mean it's the
law you know what am I supposed to do my
point is my point is to yours because I
love your special and you think in your
head you didn't like it or you're afraid
afraid that people didn't like it or
whatever that's how I woke up I woke up
yesterday morning Saint Patty's Day
that's big [ __ ] yeah the show planned
and what happens when you do press for a
special is it really get your mind off
of it so these first few days when
people are sending in tweets and
instagrams and and you don't really look
at it because you're busy working and
promoting and texting and and you know
hitting up friends hey can you tweet
about this and so then you don't really
realize it until I come Friday and then
bikeway come Friday
everyone's there for the weekend it's
your fans hitting you up
so you don't think about it I woke up
yesterday [ __ ] panicked I mean all
you can remember are the jokes you're
not proud of is like it's like yes god
damn it and then this morning was the
first time I did any real legit press
where I called in two radio stations and
they were like oh man I love that joke
you have about beating your wife or the
mop and I'm like oh that's a good joke
or the I had a joke that I had a joke
that went that they memed
like it that's nice I wrote it 18 months
ago performed it filmed it November and
then 50-cent put him put it on a meme
and it was like and I didn't get any
credit but you know it's a good joke
when it gets meme yeah and so but you
don't think about those you think about
the [ __ ] ones and so it's not until you
get [ __ ] text like from like Segura
cow head or like my friends that mean
something they go hey the secret time I
thought that should I I was so terrified
that that special just sucked they just
sucked that everyone was just being nice
to me some a nice guy people like oh
yeah yeah that happened to me too you're
just like Oh everybody's just saying
that because because like I watched it
nine times you're like that's insane
he's ever done that someone's like I
watched it back to back here like no you
did and I appreciate you saying that
yeah I appreciate you making me feel
better right I remember I did a podcast
with Rogan and he goes he said I mean
you can find this clip you can you can
see the look on my face it's [ __ ]
genuine he goes hey man I watched your
special it's [ __ ] awesome and I went
really like it's genuine like Wow and I
couldn't get past that I go wait you you
really watched it and he was like yeah I
was awesome and I was like hold on like
I'm looking at like are you being
serious
like those compliments are like the
weight like Tom Pappas said man I loved
your special hi a guy like Tom Palmer
says that and you're like his new
special is good too [ __ ] awesome man
it's awesome one's clean it's not like
like mine you can't watch with your
family yeah but yeah I have what's one
joke that you wish you could take out of
a pass from that you're just like oh it
was just it wasn't it's not me anymore
or it just was - if there is one I have
I don't like the way I named I titled my
first special cuz it was back before
clickbait was a thing behind but we knew
what clickbait was but we didn't know
what it was and it wasn't there was
nothing really racist in it but it was
like let's talk about Mexicans let's
talk about
acts like it just seems racist oh yeah
now see it's tough some stuff she does
seem racist now I wat - Oh klutzy like
oh man that seems kind of racist now but
at the time it wasn't at all it wasn't
like we've also gotten so [ __ ] in
Hollywood have gotten so sensitive on
the way that things are like said yeah
and not the reality of them like I had a
joke a snobby joke about my closing joke
was about getting [ __ ]
I forgot how it went but I remember I
remember someone explaining it to me
like showing me from a woman's point of
view how that's a bit aggressive and I
just did not see it I was like I was
like I tried the censored approach no I
go I go you know women hate when you
grab by the back of the head and
strong-arm him down I go you guys see
the look on their face we're like no I
go I tried the censored approach you
know sliding it in their mouth while
they're sleeping just like you're
dreaming you're dreaming you're
snorkeling and the keys feel the fish
bouncing off your chin so like I eat
those remember this girl going like it
sounds like you're raping your wife I go
oh no no I'm just [ __ ] her sleep
she's like and I was like yeah but what
do you yeah but that was a different
time you could [ __ ] the sleep back
then you know called the old moccasins
it was actually a lot of women were like
thank you for not waking me up I
guarantee you if my wife could find a
way that he slept she would take it
that's a that's what I'm saying a lot of
wives would consent in advance you're
saying yes please I had a joke and one
of my specials about I took it out
because it just didn't sound right I
maybe I didn't take it out I don't might
be a secret time ago you ever had sex
with someone who didn't want to have sex
with you not rape but like what ever
[ __ ] your wife when she doesn't want to
[ __ ] you and she's just like hmm and
you're like you're not really into this
it's like no I don't want to be doing
this at all and you're like huh like no
I'm just want to go to Target I don't
want to deal with an [ __ ] yeah I miss
wording that joke I think I told that
secret time I don't know yeah I never
had a wife but I could imagine you get
married I think I would like to is it
really if is it pretty cool I love it
you do I love it yeah you've always been
a big proponent of it yeah but I'm a big
I was a better I was I'm a better
married dude I am single day yeah I
could see that you need
bril that net around you need that
support you need that when you go home
you got that love you got something
going on there's something fun I can't I
can't my I mean I I look at like you and
dilly I know daliyah's now got kid but
like I look at you D'Elia and like that
group of guys who all kind of like
untethered and I go that must be nice to
like go like I'm going on the road you
know I'm gonna stay on the road and then
just go snow ski and then go into
another city or I'm gonna do a movie and
disappear for a month or or like or like
in times like this where you go I don't
have to worry about like financially I'm
good for a couple years you know but
right now as a parent and these happen
you start worrying about your kids you
start writing about finances and you're
like like I know I'm good but like for
how long and how long like if and by the
way if [ __ ] goes sideways I still got to
take care of like say the economy never
recovers never for like five years and
they can no one goes see stand-up I
don't really have any more [ __ ] skill
sets right but you could disappear and
go Bart and be the [ __ ] funny
bartender make $100,000 a year you know
yeah may you'd be way funnier but no I
think there's definitely like oh yeah
there's a it's definitely you start to
see guys like Sebastian got married and
started a family you know you don't see
ya Ernst you see guys start to have kids
and stuff you're like oh man I guess I
guess this is something I have to do if
I want to do it you know I just actually
at some point I got to start to go down
that road you know so time yeah yeah you
gotta find the right check you got to
find the right chicken yeah that's
another thing you don't want to find
some up you know you don't want to find
some [ __ ] dust mop it out there was
you know copping grams when you're not
around or doing [ __ ] like that stealing
[ __ ] from you so I've had some chicks
sell some of my [ __ ] you know when you
were partying did you date like sketchy
chicks oh I've always kind of dated
something so a couple of real schedules
my last girlfriend wasn't sketchy though
I don't know if I've made good
girlfriend choices it's just like the
messing around choices if you're like oh
wait what's the worst I got it yeah this
time your name but just tell me like the
worst um let me think this I'm sure
oh oh I know the worst dude so there was
a girl that
I don't know she was the worst really
but there was a girl who uh there was a
girl who I had taken him bunch of stuff
from a Holiday Inn right and uh and this
back when Holiday and put wrote holiday
and when they're like on the shower
curtains and stuff in their showers and
the soaps and everything no but I'd
hooked up with her at her place and then
I took all that stuff and redid her
bathroom in it and to put all holiday
and [ __ ] in there but that did another
to do with her I think she there was and
then I cheated on her that was more me
let me do another one
yeah she was super sketch girl where I
pass that her house on visitor hamper
that wasn't her that was more me you
know trying to think I mean I'm sure
some oh I remember one time hooking up
with this young lady and she's like oh
you can bust right inside of me you know
immediately I maybe not want to even be
around her that just revolted me to my
core that she was just you know just
even like I'm not gonna hack you later
all that's my new thing is I don't bust
man if I'm having sex we have sex for a
little while we go our separate ways huh
I was ejaculate later by myself all are
all ejaculate you know at a future time
you weren't jerking off for a while
right yeah I've been through some good
phases man I've struggled recently but
I'm doing my best you know why how come
I don't like it man oh and the girl goes
yeah you can bust inside of me she goes
I was like I don't want to do all of
that you know she's like oh don't worry
I can't get pregnant I don't even have
any ovaries that's what she yelled out
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] what's the place for
you buy printer ink and everything
Kinkos no no no a little bit bigger than
that oh I don't even got any ovary and
the middle billiards match in a skins
game long story I'll just say me and an
octopus didn't get along ah so that
still ruminates inside it makes me sad
[Laughter]
with that girl I did it so I did it
sketchy checks but never I never [ __ ]
them I was always weird about [ __ ]
checks oh yeah dude same man I was for a
while I wasn't even good at it sex at
all minute I'm still never I've never
been good at not good at oh I'm not good
at swearing a lot of times no I just I
bust so [ __ ] quick oh wow I'm like
literally I don't think I get AIDS it's
like the five-second rule when you drop
some on the ground like all right that
doesn't count yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm not
like you want to see you with AIDS but I
couldn't imagine you with a yeah
pictures when I was skinnier
yeah dude I'd be an ugly AIDS patient oh
dude I had a [ __ ] ugly head
really I had an ugly head I've always
had an ugly head and when I gained
weight my head looked normal on my body
oh I could see that like I have a big I
have a big head like a size like put
this on your head and feel how big my
head it's pretty big oh wow that's your
head that's my head oh my god I feel
like I'm in a little apartment I know I
feel like I'm in a studio apartment like
hold on I'll go over here to the kids
yeah sorry I didn't do my hair it
normally looks a lot better but I'm
starting to get gray streaks in my hair
oh yeah gray streaks in my beard I'm
getting that we got a question right
here from a guy named John gu looks like
an Islamic
faintly wake up it's your bud John
what's up Johnny Johnny Johnny totally
gay best friend I saw a question for
Burt given that Theo is in a 12-step
program and a big part of that program
is acceptance and forgiveness do you
think that you would ever forgive Ari
Shaffir for unintentionally drugging you
and giving you Molly so hope you're back
gang gang take a question very now he
said he said unintended
I think that's where we differ I think
he was pretty direct in his intent do
you think he wanted to do it like just
do you think there's something in him
that's like I got to get a rise somehow
out of things and it doesn't matter what
it is it doesn't matter if it's like you
know just his vibe of humor with the
COBE stuff you know like heard not just
Kobe but all that going to the edge you
know I got a douse my friend I got to do
this fire I mean I think I think the two
are separate
I think but I'll say number one I think
always always succeeded on those outer
barriers of comedy media really pushing
the edge really finding the boundary and
then and then jumping over it yeah case
in point the the Kobe thing the the I'm
not gonna go through Ari's list of the
things there but even the picture of him
naked on the stage like he's always at
the a you know he's always done the /
he's always he's doing the dark side of
the moon a lot of times yeah 100% I
think I do think there's a part I think
there's a part of already that thought
if we do a podcast and I've sort of a
Molly it's gonna be the most epic
podcast ever yeah everyone was talking
about further Esther their lives and I
think he I think that was a part of his
thought process but I do think that part
of his intent was this is gonna be a
blast first one of my best friends
I think Molly's not gonna kill him I'm
gonna give him Molly we're gonna get
high we're gonna laugh we hang out all
night he didn't really calculate it like
he was like I should have checked to see
if his kids were in the other room I
should have checked to see if they make
dinner or something
my wife was making dinner for all both
of us wouldn't have dinner with the
girls because my girls loved Ari and and
and he's like and he didn't check that I
was flying that night I was starting my
tour that
so there's a lot of things I didn't like
check the boxes for he just kind of did
it and and it was mean it's super
regrettable because I still love Ari and
I and I'm we're still friends we text
all the time we talk on the phone but
like if my daughter sees me texting with
Ari still take my phone she [ __ ]
Georgia hate sorry
Leanne hate sorry and that's what
[ __ ] sucks and that I'll never
release the podcast cuz I just don't I
know for a fact already thinks it's that
big but I've talked too much about it so
if you watch it yeah you'd know too much
about my feelings about what happened I
suppose if I had never spoken about it
and I just released it I would have been
I mean it would have but I think it
would probably got off without a hitch
but I talked about it so much mmm that I
just I feel like it's not fair to show
it's not fair to show Ari being somewhat
insensitive to a friend who believes he
was drugged and may die right cuz or
he's just he's hi and he doesn't care
and I'm freaked out I'm having a panic
attack and you can definitely see all
that and I know Ari feels differently
but will you one day put him on a
paywall you think no I mean maybe it
maybe one day like release it as a movie
may I may I mean
it's by the way it's not it's so crazy
like if you say you heard you like
others outtakes on Reservoir Dogs where
they lose memory there's I'll takes on
Lily Tomlin losing her mind on Dustin
Hoffman or someone during a movie
totally I think you see something and
they were like oh I want to see that and
you as a fan as a fan of podcasts as a
fan like a perfect example right when
you and Bill bird in a podcast and
everyone was like bro what the [ __ ]
happened there I went right there
excited I watched it I didn't see what I
think everyone else saw like I just saw
you and Bill hanging out it didn't
didn't register for me the way it did
for other people but I ran right to it I
I ran right to it
people on Twitter what what the [ __ ]
happened with Bill and Theo and I was
like Bill's one of my best friends I've
know the I feel is one of my close
friends like I've known bill for 20
years I've known Theo for 15 like I'm
[ __ ] I'm going here for me it didn't
like razzle-dazzle me I can see what
people were talking about I can pick up
on hints of it but like
it wasn't what I want to see so I know
as a fan the idea that you'd want to
watch me and re me get drugged I'm just
afraid protective of re that especially
with all the Cobie [ __ ] the one yeah but
we just it wouldn't help anyone really
wouldn't help any trust me man had I
released it in that Kobe [ __ ] gone viral
people would have grabbed that and it
would have here it's lugging us a white
guy I mean do I'll tell you right now
when it happened dr. Drew said you know
just so you know you by you telling me
this I have to call the police and I
went then I made it up then I don't know
what you're talking about so if I put it
out there would have been I think it
would've been a bad I already disagrees
100% Wow so Ari says put it out already
wants it out so bad maybe I'll sell it
to him one day there you go yeah we're
talking if he makes it big which on the
rate he's at he's big man he's just
[ __ ] sabotaging himself left and
[ __ ] right he's the guy that killed
Kobe Ryan pretty much yeah you know and
a lot of yeah and a lot of poorly
written articles you know here's the guy
and look at this the guy was flying now
the copters picture of Ari sometimes you
know what I say and it's bad like bro
things you've mixed up out there it's a
mash-up yeah he's so talented man and I
think that when he does film the special
called Jew I think it's called because
he's a Jewish supremacist he's a Jewish
yeah 100% when he's films this special I
think it's gonna be huge and I think
people I think it'll really I think
people will see the the artist as
opposed to like the comic that we've all
known right the sensitive sweet [ __ ]
hilarious
Ari Shaffir as opposed to bloody ass rag
by the way that's still part of his
personalities Doug Stanhope a piss on
you and he's one of the most genius
comics in the world
yeah it's like you can be both people
you can give me three things you me four
things yeah yeah yeah I don't know we
didn't I like I remember asking if you
wanted to talk about it one day on the
podcast and just through texting and
then I never heard back from him about
it but yeah it's interesting because if
I if I here's what here's what you
should do if you talk to him make him
talk honestly right because this here's
what here's what is frustrating to me is
that the cop it's not even frustrating
it's not even frustrating at all
like the part of Arie that apologized
and the part that I talked to on the
phone at the end of the month when we
hadn't spoken for a month and he had
texted me every single day going like I
want to talk to you I can't have this
happen I can't lose you as a friend like
that guy right that guy talking about it
and talking about his experience dude
that way is so [ __ ] fascinating the
part of him were it's where he shuts off
and de flex and goes what is a joke
right
you know that for me I'm not super
fascinated by but man I know that I know
the man very [ __ ] well yeah and the
sensitive side I would love to hear his
perspective of it from more human space
and now he was here because it's funny
still like his like hit me and him
talking the first time we talked I was
driving to a plan of fitness in an uber
and me and him talked I can see that and
we were just back and forth kind of
having our first conversation in a month
but giggling and kind of like like yeah
that was a [ __ ] do you like I'd say
something like and then instead of going
like deflected he was [ __ ] but you
know what that's me asking him in to do
comedy and that's offensive right me to
go hey this is how you should talk about
it my point is I would look that side of
alright I would love to hear on a
podcast right right oh yeah man I mean
yeah he's definitely a sweet nice dude I
think you know says this wild character
that is though he is God is this outlaw
he's like the Jesse James kind of like
things I can't you can't change that
that's his whole thing and that's a real
thing no yeah it's really [ __ ] on Bobby
Lee's car yeah he beat up Bobby Lee four
times there's a part of Arie that's a
[ __ ] legit wild card
I let me tell you so how do you beat up
I believe three times and then go back
and beat him up one more time now I
don't know I mean it seems like it was
an easy fight dude or lower cuts any
cuts dude any cuts you could use a bobby
bobby BAM Bobby Lee Bobby Lee's so cool
no deaf unbelievably one-of-a-kind you
and him are the two dudes in recovery
that have never ever been brow beady or
like
never been like like you know like when
I say [ __ ] like y'all yeah I'm not
drinking right now and you're like nice
and you like ass I'm a hard time
sleeping or whatever and I don't know
what I said to you last time I said
something about not drinking and you're
like yeah you and you just got like I
heard by know you're talking about and
then and then and then I was like
alright I'm out I'm out I'm Annie took
off but both of you I believed always
been cool about whatever [ __ ]
thoughts I have out loud just listening
and being like a friend suppose you know
some dudes are a little bit like hey man
yeah here's the deal you got a problem
in and I can help ya I can be your
Savior and you're like no you [ __ ]
can yeah run an open mic out of Burbank
and I'm not trusting my life with you at
all yeah I'd much rather be a failed
alcohol and [ __ ] your sidekick and a
[ __ ] a meeting
yeah don't make me beat up Bobby Lee
again this is probably 18 years no was
it mixed or men's mixed okay mixed is
about his men's better mins is
definitely like a little bit more it
gets like a little bit more sentimental
I think the mixed ones there's always
that element of like impressing women or
seeing what's going on a little bit oh
yeah this was no cuz they got a lot of
bottle thoughts out there a lot of
chicks you give up the liquor just to
get a man you know mm-hmm yeah by the
way I would I can see myself totally
getting sober because of a chicken AAA
oh yeah and then falling off with her
when she wanted to fall yeah I can
totally see that happening but went to a
meeting one time was over yes I
shouldn't say anything like that
booze now you see where it was on
Moorpark no no this is a long time I
live in Hollywood it was on the corner
of Franklin and and Highland mm-hmm so
it was like he's Franklin yeah Franklin
Highland it's over by that Starbucks
over there mm-hmm so everyone went to
the Starbucks and then walked Chris
Street to the to the like school library
what it was was in like an auditorium
like library type setting you go in they
give you the book and there and you sit
you know you're sitting down first and
then they're going around and then the
guy was with this really cool dude he he
and he had the only way to support him
no no no I was Lee Ann had dumped me
mm-hmm we've been dating for like four
months that she dumped me cuz I got
drunk at a party and I wouldn't let a
fight go like a what like
argument with her friends I just thought
yeah I fought I died on the hill I was
like this is my hell did I on and I got
drunk and then I couldn't rebound
emotionally from that fight and she
broke up with me and so I just said I'm
done I'm done drinking I got drunk and I
lost a chick that I loved and I don't
want that and if I want to find chicks I
love that I want to keep I got to be
sober good see that's not gonna work
yeah I feel yeah I tried to learn French
wants to get a woman back
I made a boat out of clay for a woman
once I made a mixtape for Liam you did
dude I she dumped me sorry I made a
mixtape and I drove down LaBrea sobbing
crying oh yeah sobbing crying and put it
on her car like a mixtape with a letter
and I went back in I thought I said I've
cried so hard this is how bad I was hurt
when they had dumped me I I went into my
shower cuz I'd want anyone to hear me
yeah yeah but I couldn't sit on the
ground once on the ground so I bought
one of those exercise balls in mmm but I
into the shower into the shower but it
wouldn't fit through the door so I had
to deflate it crying bring it in and
shower crying re-inflate it crying and
sit on it crying breathe deep when
you're crying too and so I'm sitting on
I lived up on this street called Glencoe
oh right oh man right above yeah yes a
sitting there eating Asian pear
I hadn't drank in a couple days I was
not out of any other thing that I've
been crying this whole time is this in
the Bible I feel like this isn't a Bible
yeah and so stewed comes out lived up
there and he goes he goes what's going
on and I said something about because he
was a how'd he get in the shower and I
was on the street on the street on the I
was on the street in Asian pear
apartment so he used to be a sober coach
so they'd hire him oh yeah that's a big
job he they'd hire him to go with huge
actors to their movie to keep them sober
so that they could get insured get
through it Denzel Washington as a man
everybody talks about a lot of times he
gets
sober for films oh yeah yeah it was here
that anyway it's a rumor so this guy
then that's what he did for them he made
great money and he was a nice man tall
guy and coolest shoe a guy who'd got no
yoke good-looking dude Harley
Connie Corso dog like just the [ __ ]
he was the man right and so he just sit
and he's and he knew all the talk man
knew but he was like in like he had been
sober for a while and he'd been doing
this so long and trying to get you in a
took you to a meeting he just know you
always said was he goes I saw him think
I quit drinking for a while
and he was like how long I don't know
and he was like he's like you know
sometimes it's just it's easier to just
go let's just take today yeah I don't
worry about when you're gonna start just
take today I was like maybe I should and
he goes and if you want if you need help
today like why don't you come to a
meeting with me
and I was like I was like man I'm my
fear was I was gonna start drinking so I
was so depressed about with the N Dom
mean and so I said I'll go I was due I
was
I'll try was like I'll try anything I
was like I'll go to a meeting this is
new yeah we went out we got coffee I'd
never had coffee at night oh yeah I'd
never done that we got coffee we went to
the meeting and he was like just just
listen man you want to do anything just
listen so they're going around
everyone's talking and it's like four
guys for me and he hits me and he goes
he goes hey listen I know your comic if
you want to talk if you want to talk
about we're going to everyone's gonna
listen and I was like really
he was like yeah just just spill
everything you don't have to be funny
just spill everything I was like alright
alright good call
so I'm sitting and then it gets to me
and I go to sign up and this guy next to
me that I didn't really like kinda was
like behind me he stands up he goes
actually I'm having a really rough day
and I was like okay and so I sit back
down and he goes hi my name is Don Todd
I'm an alcoholic and everyone's like hi
da da da da and he goes oh it's been a
bad day I woke up this morning I sucked
my landlords dick and I lit his car on
fire
and I as a comic the oh I went how do I
follow that like an old exact so I just
like I'm [ __ ] out I'm like I'm
sitting down and then I [ __ ] I was
like never went back to another meeting
I was like yeah and I stayed sober for
eight months and and Leanne and I one
night we're in we're venison i season
for eight months dude that's huge I said
well I don't know I don't have a problem
staying sober right
problem if there is a problem my problem
is turning it on and off like I don't
really do it the way like regular people
do it
we're like like I don't drink during the
days I only drink at nights but in a
weird way it's like I get the I get the
itch so like 8 o'clock or 7 o'clock
sansar statin I would my gosh wine yeah
but once I stopped drinking like we stew
so rocktober I have no problem not
drinking right and by the way I have a
hard time starting drinking again
mmm once I start November first I'm back
in I'm back in the game like this it's
it's not every night but it's pretty
much like any night I'm on the road the
road must be tough man being sober on
the road was really tough because you
get done a show and you just sitting
there like so now what what do we eat
like yeah what are we gonna do want to
smoke cigars and so now you're smoking
three cigars a day and so and I was
working I was being so healthy but you I
don't know when I can drink on the road
I just do it so yeah I would I feel like
if I'm out there especially I'm out
there on a tour bus and stuff like that
I would just yeah I would probably just
be getting hammered out there I feel
like it would be real risky what was
this question we had right here from a
young feller a woman and this is a man
it's kind of what you just talked about
oh yeah Lois this message is for birth
me and Theo come from the same cloth
looks like I'm coming from God but how
do you drink so much and stop for sober
October how do you do that I can't even
imagine just stop and drinking like that
without any program or anything like
that how do you do it Burke Gang Gang
way how do you yeah how do you do that
you just shut it down you me you know do
you know ramping up until October you
like okay September I'm gonna drink as
much I got a I got a we're gonna have
this last night is gonna be a big party
you have a party the night before no
yeah no actually usually I'll quit
drinking a couple days before just kind
of Pratt know just because like I go I
don't want to ramp up and be hungover
October first where I'm like oh I'd
rather have that [ __ ] day here so that
if I need a glass of wine to go to bed
like if I'm like you know I'm gonna have
a glass of wine
so like I've kind of tapered it off and
then and then I just stop I've done it
both ways I've did it this last year I
got [ __ ] wasted September 30th or
whatever and then turned it off the year
before I kind of tapered off a little
bit the year before that I think I the I
think I didn't drink because the rule is
you can't you got to stop drinking at
midnight right so you can't you can't
build up to midnight and then go I'm
done that's not gonna happen
yeah so like I always taper it off a tad
bit but uh yeah I don't know man I have
a weird thing in my head it's very
punitive I'm very punitive I'm a little
obsessive compulsive so like like what
I'm not drinking right now I'm not gonna
drink for the next probably I mean I may
I never anybody drink in here no no no
no no I meant I'm not drinking right now
this time of my life oh I see you're
saying it so we got a lot of work to do
too right now
yeah and I've plenty of [ __ ] free
time I'm like dude last thing I'm gonna
do is [ __ ] a bunch of free time up with
booze yeah it's like when you go on
vacation my biggest mistake when I was
younger is I go on vacation and get
[ __ ] wasted those final time come
home and be like more tired from the
vacation life yeah I went on vacation
one time to Hawaii my wife's like no
booze I did it and I had a [ __ ] blast
up early jogging swimming snorkeling oh
look the greatest vacation so I lost to
you oh dude
LeAnn lumps good out here oh when I'm
out there I feel like I'm supposed to be
out there me too
you know what we did in Fiji we kind of
floated the reef or they drop you off
and you just kind of cruise with the
reef oh it sleazy pretty cool Fiji was
[ __ ] awesome it was really great
that's a Fiji Bali Fiji is great too oh
wow Wyndham Fiji as well Fiji is amazing
but Bali's [ __ ] legit
I don't know I wish I could tell you I
talked dr. drew about it why I get to
this place where I shut it down and then
I don't and then I'll tell you right now
man if I see if I don't drink for this
whole time we're off for whatever time
we're off I'll have a really hard time
starting again do you feel like you have
to drink cause your show and cuz your
act I think I think people would be
really I think people would probably
look at me different I think people look
at my show is I got a reason to tap out
and have a good time yeah and I think
they I think let's go celebrate
I'm also the guy that like when I go to
a party like with parents on the
guy that gives everyone a license to get
a little loaded yeah and I don't you can
never tell when I'm wasted I mean I can
but you normally people can't so so it I
feel like they go on the lips get wetter
I noticed them yeah yeah it's okay there
but um but yeah I don't know how I I
don't know I wish I knew and I've talked
to dr. Drew about on my I don't think so
here's up I think you're gonna have
health problems if you continue the way
you do it yeah so that's where I like
turning it off
yeah he's so smart - dr. Drew isn't he
dude he's the bat I'm this whole Crona
virus thing I'm texting him about like
mental health it yeah you know I've
talked about it but no one really knows
too much about it but like I definitely
have anxiety like that I can't I can
sometimes I can't deal with I think that
probably leads to me drinking but there
are times where I just like can't deal
with it and when this coronavirus kicked
off I was like and I was like I wouldn't
leaving the boss like weed like I was
like yeah I'm safe here
like why would I get out of the bus it's
out there and I mean it's worth just at
your place right now where is it
it's at my house right now yeah but uh
but like I was it like we were driving
across country who drew from New Orleans
to LA and I just was like I just wasn't
get out of the bus Wow
and they were like well I was it was
like they didn't know what was going on
so everyone's with me but I kept my head
was just chewing the same thoughts over
and over again so I called dr. drew and
he's like all right let's talk I go I'm
actually good today but so yeah he's
such a nice outlet he said I really yeah
just his tone and everything is to go
away to communicate we had a question
that came up right here from a young
woman this is a man actually young fella
Burt got a question for you if there's
no tito's available what's your what's
really good to drink and do back in your
your drinking days what was your what
was your go-to drink gang gang gang bro
well I like to do a Miller High Life was
a beer that I've really enjoyed really
and it's in Europe too and it's a beer
that I always that I've thoroughly
enjoyed was in Miller High Life and I
and I used to live with a man who would
be Tostitos at night and
during Miller Lite so sometimes I'd sit
in the living room watch him he didn't
know I was sitting there in the dark
watching him any be on the computer
looking at pornography and [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] Tostitos and drinking and Miller
Lite I used to watch him but yeah when I
was drinking what else did we have a
little bit of mad dog 20/20 was kind of
popular Ripple
a lot of the brothers would [ __ ] let
you hit that ripple jug you know yeah
and uh but yeah once we got into college
beer you know and then once I got out of
there I went through a gin and tonic
phase over there in Charleston South
Carolina onyx are beautiful oh my god
booze like I'll literally get my hopes
up yeah like I'll go like you you can
sell me on a drink yeah where I go a guy
might need one of those I talked to
someone today and he was like I'm having
a white wine I'm on the keys I'm as
coronavirus is freaking me out I just
broke up a port of white wine and it's
like 4:00 in the morning to me yeah
doing a radio tour I was like I wanna
[ __ ] glass why yeah I don't I don't
have a problem getting back on look you
like me blocking my way into back
drinking tonight look I don't have a
problem in I might drink tonight it's
only fun yeah man gin and tonics oh they
were grab Jim gin and tonics on Monday
Night Football
oh really my sister worked it's got a
job at Fox we just had Georgia and we
Stu go over to her house in like Oh down
on Pico mm-hmm my two sisters lived
together my sister I would make gin and
tonics mmm and we make dinner we'd watch
my daughter my wife we go to tennis
practice my other sister would come home
and we'd all grill out have gin and
tonics gin and tonics remind me at
Monday Night Football that's awesome man
it's such a we drink them out at this
place I remember was called and just
stand out there and look at the grass
and have a couple gin and tonics brother
they had like you know like a lot of
like marsh grass and Paul meadows and
stuff like that so this is in South
Carolina and we drink nine of them
eleven of them man [ __ ] drink those
[ __ ] to your eyes wouldn't close you
know it's funny I don't enjoy this have
to lay a rag over my eyes to sleep I
couldn't get my eyes closed if I had
enough too much gin I couldn't I never I
know I don't really love the taste of
Tito's and sodas I love the taste of a
gin and tonic
yeah like I love the taste of a Bloody
Mary a strong Bloody Mary spicy I love
taste love the taste of a White Russian
oh yeah I love the taste I just got back
into IPAs I wasn't a guy yeah I had a
period where I couldn't drink IPAs I was
drinking one in the morning yeah I was
taking a shower I had to jump off the
stratosphere that day that no wow I was
in the shower in Utah and I had a it
call it a gravity jug and it was like a
really strong IPA and I was getting
ready to go on a plane I'm drinking in
the shower cuz I don't want to [ __ ]
fly I'm so much anxiety and I'm running
late for the fight and I drank too much
and I threw up an IPS strong IPA any
shower
oh it's thinking about it it's too much
huh
I couldn't drink IPAs for a long time
and then once those tannins and stuff
from that oak or whatever gets to just
get to your gills do you know what you
know what I miss because I can't drink
it someone blood pressure medicine is
grapefruit and vodka oh wow and a
grapefruit and gin is [ __ ] awesome
he's even in every drink on jack on the
rocks double jack on the rocks lots of
ice that's my take off drink on planes
oh really down on a plane what do you
want sir I'll take a double Jack in the
rocks lots of ice lots of ice please
these are how I take mine these are my
orders is this is when you know you
drink too much these are my orders okay
tt does sort of big last no lime can I
get a double jack on the rocks lots ice
can I get a beer but pour in the glass
just pour the whole thing in glass do
not just give me the cam okay no no
actually I think you give me the cam
give it important the guys I mean I'm
really specific about how I take drinks
but look I think is also I think man as
they get older they get specific about
how they take everything you know it's
not like yeah
don't give me this like you're just like
I'm 19 again it was when you were
kidding you'd have to call your dad like
how do I like my steak medium-rare how
do I get this tied of work yeah how do I
do this now it took you know exactly how
you want things it's just like okay this
is how I do tur I don't do it at all do
you remember it was like the first time
you ever bought a car and you like you
picked it out paid cash boy 1984 Ford
Escort dude with no passenger seat
somebody stole well somebody stole it
but it had it when I got it but I think
the guy stole it back the guy I bought
it from really yeah I never really went
into it but I do think that but like the
first car you bought like that you went
into a dealership and you said like I'm
looking at I'm looking
this guy showed you things and you were
like he's like what color would you like
and you had to make all these decisions
on your own there's my first car was a
Expedition an Eddie Bauer or nice black
on Tanner's God I remember looking at it
and going this is the car like it
I want the tan interior bleep in the
back yeah oh I slept in that back a lot
i [ __ ] [ __ ] lianna in the driver's
seat 1d key really yes you slammed my
dunk my thumb in the car door and I
didn't care I just kept banging away
middle of the night that thumb started
hurting more than I've ever felt
anything hurt and she took a needle
littered over a match and pushed it in
popped it and blood squirted out [ __ ]
thumb that was the most pain as part of
most pain I've ever been in my life that
[ __ ] thumb yeah the fingers are
really it's amazing kind of sometimes
what's in there you know you wonder
what's in your hands all the time have
you seen that show my feet are killing
me mmm I don't want that kind of stuff
we got a question when you answer my Oh
Jon REEP it's Nick from Melbourne
Australia
cheers man my questions for Bert did the
LA Marathon did the triathlon what's
next surely we can squeeze a big bike
ride or something out of you gang gang
game brother yeah bird it's crazy good
for one end of the spectrum you hit you
hit the other end of the spectrum too
man some real pinnacles athletically
yeah I wrote I already wrote a bike I
rode a bike from Philadelphia to
Atlantic City I was that far is it
really
it took me five hours oh wow dude it was
I was probably the hardest thing I've
ever done because I had partied the
night before but I was at my biggest I
never been weight wise so I wrote it and
it was just I mean there's a lot of
gunplay over there in Philly - now we're
25 and about how many miles is it 68.4
68.4 it was Lu [ __ ] some sharp five
hours in 22 minutes I did it much longer
by the way I think I did it like five
hours
I almost if I did in six hours how
congratulations man that's amazing
we're talking about swimming in the
Catalina channel me and my buddy you
know Dave Williamson comedian
oh yeah a bleep man Dave from Miami he
tours with me and Dave wants to swim the
Catalina channel
Wow and I was like you're gonna train
for it I might as well
train for and see if I can do it I'd
rather swim with a guy so if the shark
goes after him oh yeah and it's some
people you always want to have that
shark buddy like yeah let's get into
yeah
well get a couple tattoos of meat on
your legs and this is your third or
fourth special the MUC fourth Wow yeah
my fourth and then what gets easier
about them as you go along
really yeah it's actually gotten harder
yeah because it's like the comfortably
dumb
I just told all the jokes I had right
that was it I was like whatever first
best way yeah
the machine I had a good length of time
between now like probably I want to say
like eight years or something I don't
know when I did the machine but like
maybe seven years five years by sometime
and I had this machine story worked out
I knew that was the end I knew that was
gonna end it and I had these great
stories I had these stories that were
really working like fighting a bear
gentleman I have a plan with Rachael Ray
the machines right all I need to do is
tether them together and it was ice and
by the way there's no pressure with
Showtime everyone was like no one's
gonna watch it and no one did but that
machine story went viral so then there
was like a little bit of an expectation
when I did my next one but not much cuz
Netflix was like yeah well we'll do a
special with you they didn't say like we
want to do a special they were like
we'll do a special with you so we did
the seeger time and see what time was
the first ever successful thing I ever
did in my life
Wow where I was like there was actually
no lie that was the first successful
thing I ever did in my entire [ __ ]
career and by the way I'd been in the
business 20 years Wow and that was the
first thing I did anyone ever what
determined for you that it was
successful I was able to sell a tour I
was able to sell I say I did secret time
and then like I mean the meet when this
machine went viral that sold out comedy
clubs for like two years two years
straight three years I could do sell it
all comedy clubs and then when I did
secret time that everyone you know your
team says alright we're gonna make the
leap to theaters and you're like I don't
really give a [ __ ] the money of comedy
clubs is just fine and then you gotta
take a hit unless you do really
successful when Sieber time came out I
just didn't have the rate
like I know I didn't know that people
watched it I didn't know that anyone
liked it I didn't know that it was any
good I didn't I didn't have any idea
what I was doing I just did it
I did these were the thoughts I had I
hung out with Thalia Delia said no one
watched after 30 minutes is special so
for secret time based on that simple
conversation I had with Thalia I took
all the best material that I had that
had been spread throughout with a closer
I moved the closer to 22 minutes I took
anything that popped and I moved it up
front mmm like I just I front loaded the
[ __ ] out of that special huh and because
I did people got to the closure and were
like well [ __ ] I'll watch the rest of
it mm-hmm and so that was like probably
the easiest I had no shame about it I
know you're voting the [ __ ] out of
excited n't I was like I've been failing
my whole life this is gonna fail but I'm
not gonna let it fail I'm gonna just
swing every attempt I get I'm gonna
swing for the fences and try to get it
succeed and then it did and then this
one was like like when you say this one
was really stressful because I I was
like I'm doing I'm trying some different
stuff I'm I'm doing the stuff that I do
well like talk about my daughters
talking about my wife talking about my
family talking about being a bad dad
about drinking we got an adventure story
like I'd do all the things but then I
was like I would watch comics that I
loved
dude the exact same thing that they had
done in the previous special meaning
like keep riding the same pony same
exact same horse another change I never
changed in it and a bum me out so I was
like in my head silently I go I thought
you were better than that but then long
I thought you were better than me and I
know I wouldn't do that and BRR was like
[ __ ] you know BRR BRR Rogan or two
dudes that have said throw away things
to me that I've hung my [ __ ] hat on
Wow
verse at one time if you something
effective if you're not challenging
yourself then you're not getting better
and if you're not getting better then
why would anyone want to watch you hmm
so I legit challenge myself I said I
said I talked to stand out and Stanhope
who says it was he was like he was
drinking one morning and he I was like
what are you doing he goes I'm writing a
knock-knock jokes
I don't what he's a camera and goofs man
like just goofs
you know I'm [ __ ] around I'm not
writing material I'm just just you know
working with my work in his brain yeah
getting the brain to
yeah do something he's like where's
funny as those guys right we gotta be as
funny as those guys I was like yeah he
said there's no way they're funnier than
we were we're funny so why can't we
write knock-knock jokes huh yeah why not
and then I started getting obsessed with
noir MacDonald he's a guy that could
write a knock-knock joke like he's a guy
yeah who could take a standard structure
joke and then and then make it now me
I'll speak I'll speak only for me but I
think all of us me you segura like our
group of guys D'Elia
Santino ever all while all of us we do
what we do in our own way and but it's
not traditional stand-up right and I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna go into that
like go into like I'm gonna do
traditional stand-up I was like I got
would like to challenge myself to write
a guy walks into a bar joke yeah
and so I did it and I think it's good
and I think it's probably the best joke
I've ever written but I don't think
you'd know it's a guy walks into a bar
joke until if I unless I told you and
then you go oh [ __ ]
and so and like so I did I did that I
tried to do this thing about this gun
bit which i think is one of the better
bits I've ever I've seen that I've see I
believe that I've seen a sight seen
either but at the Comedy Store man yeah
I thought it was so good yeah and so I
just try to challenge myself and if I
succeeded then I'm break but if I didn't
then if I didn't you still got the stuff
you loved what I did and I think these I
think I look how it's the exactly you
said about your special that's how I
feel right now I'm super proud of this
[ __ ] thing but like you don't know
yeah I don't want to be like some guy
that's like and who would I be if I yeah
I think there's a there's definitely a
thing of learning to be proud of things
and then there's also a thing of
constantly okay how do i how am I gonna
challenge myself again where am I gonna
move the bar am I gonna stay in this
safe take a look at where you've
challenged yourself like I heard a joke
that you threw away the other day and I
thought old Theo Sartre someone's
telling me this joke it was a throwaway
I brought it up to you and he's like oh
yeah whatever
and I thought old Theo would have hung
his hat on that joke and that would have
been his act and that would have been he
was had every night on stage where you
are today because you've challenged
yourself and taken [ __ ] big strides
now you're [ __ ] where you're at in
stand-ups next [ __ ] level but you got
it we always challenge ourselves when
are you we were younger yeah always
think about it if you stayed where you
were an open mic or and you were like
I'm getting laughs that's what I'll do
we
and we know those guys yeah then they
stayed here the whole time but instead
some guys you get those laughs in over
mics you're like I'm actually better
than those cheap laughs I got this yeah
the cheap laughs scare me now cuz
sometimes I want to tell a joke I don't
know something new to do yeah and I'm in
but don't say too much but I want to do
something new and I'll be like man
there's a couple of cheap jokes that I
really like that yeah five eight years
ago I'd have been like oh definitely now
I'm like I just can't do that it's not
gonna make me feel good
dude when we work together in in San
Francisco and you sat down and you told
like a solid eight minute story about
that Mexican man that went to school
with you oh yeah I'm on the floor you
would have never had the balls to do
that in I was like eight hundred people
you would never had the balls to do that
when you first started but you
challenged yourself and challenge
yourself and I think we have to keep
doing that as comics when we do specials
we can't just go well secret time worked
let me just do a carbon copy of that
change out the punch lines but same
structure a structure works yeah why
wouldn't I do that again well I think
it's I think it's you know and I might
be thinking way too much about it I know
that many pine guys like real gonna
probably like dude just be funny bird
birds birds even after all birds advice
he'd be like bro just be funny
remember that's like the rule yeah if
you don't to be you don't have to
[ __ ] sit here like a workout they
have to save the world would enough to
yeah you have to be funny
yeah but also at a certain point you
have to make yourself laugh to are you
yeah you have to are you just not gonna
care about it it is not gonna be unless
you're a joke writer if you're a
storyteller than I think it's different
you know I think we're storytellers and
I think we take people places and yeah a
good storyteller you you gotta like you
gotta figure out new ways I mean the way
you're telling stories now man no one's
doing it like you and and thanks man
what's the truth and everyone talks
about it [ __ ] everyone talks about it
and but but you didn't just show up with
that you had to work there right and so
why would you ignore that why would you
go okay I'm here I'm done I'll just do
this for the right I'll do this exact
same thing for the rest of my life but
do you ever think like oh I'm gonna be
stuck do you ever think though that I'm
gonna be stuck here like I'm just gonna
be able to do this or do you think like
okay I will continue to evolve do you
ever just wonder for yourself like will
I continue to evolve I think everybody
kind of wonders that like I would always
the gas tank gonna run out you know I
feel like that goes well cuz you know I
get in my own way it's like excited
travel channel for so long and then when
I got out of traffic channel I was like
I was I found success in podcasting and
stand-up and that was it and I went [ __ ]
it I'm done and I literally turned a
middle finger to everyone in Hollywood
and they'd be like hey we want to do
this I would pass oh well you do this
pass and then everyone came at me with
the project and I passed on everything
and then one day I went I like I like I
remember someone got like a movie I mean
Tom did a movie maybe or something I
only say Tom's I talk to him so much but
like he Tom did a movie with Marky Mark
and I was like why would you do that he
was like well you got it you got it try
any stuff and I was like what do you
mean trying to like it's it's who what's
[ __ ] wants to be a movie with Mark
Wahlberg and he was like it's a life
experience don't you want to try [ __ ]
and then I was like oh yeah maybe I
should
maybe I should also maybe I have time to
also do other stuff mmm and then I was
like okay like I'll do is let's do a
series and so we did it we did a series
of Netflix and then I was like I was
like oh maybe we can do a sitcom I
wouldn't mind doing a sitcom and then I
started going like ham cool doing a
movie also like I'm not I can I can be
in this Lane and then do other stuff
around I got in this mindset where I
look at you look at Rogan who's not
[ __ ] who he's our Messiah man I don't
mean that like you know maybe like he's
our guy like right he's a template he's
a template and he's put us all over and
gave us our all amazing opportunities
and every single one of us acknowledge
it but in acknowledgment you also see
that path that he carved through stone
for himself and you realize if I stay in
that path I got a great life like I can
just do podcast just to stand up do
spots at the store The Improv the
Icehouse and [ __ ] in there is room to
grow yeah
but you can also gotta go amen I'm also
not Joe I'm not the best listener like
yeah I'm not the best interviewer I'm I
don't know what I'm maestro there no I
have no discipline honest smart I'm not
as smart like so like so like maybe I
should also try the things that I'm also
really good I'm saying that for myself
yeah myself to myself yeah oh I'm
[ __ ] I'm
a window licking ninny well yeah I'm
definitely saying that you're not as
smart but yeah we're not as smart
I'm not Jill Rogan I'll tell you that
man I found that out many times the hard
way yeah Joe Rogan I think
there's Larry something in Moe that's
funny dude why can't wait to see it man
I haven't watched it yet but I'm looking
forward to it appreciate the last
special I watched was Jim Gaffigan I
really really loved it the one I get on
Amazon I thought was really good listen
I'd love to I love calf kids one of the
guy he's so funny he's one of the greats
man yeah but he really is let's talk
about growth he was not who he is today
when he started hit some of my favorite
jokes his were dirty jokes like Arizona
me you ever go to you ever go back to
high school and all the kids when I call
you the nickname that called you in high
school but you grew out of it you're
like hey guys not anymore and they're
like well if it is an old sheep [ __ ]
he goes one of my favorite American
jokes he goes hey ladies you ever go to
the park on a Sunday and see that guy
walking around with his shirt off with a
snake around his neck and go man I want
to have sex with that guy and they're
like no and he goes oh hey fellas anyone
want to buy a snake Jim Gaffigan is the
funniest [ __ ] guy alive so funny is
so [ __ ] funny and he's worked so he's
been touring for what 15 years oh he's
been dude he's been told just quit to do
movies I watched his most recent movies
movies don't even know movies alter just
won't where he killed the baby no I
didn't see a little more ease the uber
driver that wouldn't have to worry baby
oh I didn't notice the baby part is that
a big part the baby died it's good man
it's almost the whole thing super babied
he put some trash away quickly
cried oh it was great man he was in
Super Troopers was he yeah they talked
about it they said he flew in on a
private jet came in shot his scene
walked off it was super cool walked off
got in his private jet one pack and they
were like thank you
yeah damn dude hey I gotta be honest
with you man to end this podcast
as a fan of your since day one you know
I've been a day one fan yeah [ __ ]
love watching you blow up man no thanks
[ __ ] fun I'm so [ __ ] fun
you make me giggle so hard I was telling
you you and that Tommy Lauren and
[ __ ] interview I want you in CJ I I
love your podcast you're killing it bro
you're killing it well thanks for just
being so supportive man and thanks for
just yeah like being supportive over the
years and being like you know just kind
of a leader in this whole industry I
mean you do the same thing you know you
work really hard and you mean you're one
of the guys to that I think a lot of
people think about like oh this guy
works so hard you know I think we're all
put thank this will be the the next few
weeks will be the test of like let's see
you can work the hardest cuz I know we
got it we got to produce something we're
all doubling down on podcast maybe write
a script or [ __ ] shoot some [ __ ] who
knows I would be great if all of us did
a project together it seems like if we
wrote something and just funded
something ourselves
dang it I would love like a big almost
like DC cab yeah remember DC cab I don't
remember it at all it was great Charlie
Barnet was in it mr. t was in it Bill
Maher was in it
oh so [ __ ] great it was about a cab
company I see something that would be
great I thought of like a wrestling
league like it's sputtering out and it's
like the last legs of it the last few
wrestlers were yes the last few
wrestlers are us and it's just the dying
last couple of fights we get a wig for
Rogan and he's got long stringy balding
hair oh that would be great I like that
Joey Diaz is a manager tremendous some
[ __ ] wrestling league we're all just
beating Bobby Lee oh that's not a bad
script Oh be so good I have anyone heard
that let's make that movie yeah somebody
wants to fund yeah somebody want to come
in with a two million dollar budget man
we can get that thing made yeah well
maybe not wood made totally because we
can't be around each other in groups of
ten but what if we did a movie where
people all have to be six feet away from
each other during the shooting of it ooh
we'll call it ski school okay I think I
think
Pricer let me - man congrats on the new
specially and congrats on all your
effort and work and thanks for being
here today
[Music]
little town for me to slap that pocket
break myself
[Music]